Europe and Africa as partners a level
playing field in the interview the
president of Senegal Macky Sall mr.
president you've been Senegal's
president for almost exactly two years I
mean that's about half of your five-year
mandate what would you say about your
record so far sizzle correspond the
reason I will only have five is because
I requested a change in the Constitution
ago I was originally elected to a
seven-year term now the president is
only allowed to serve a five-year term
with one chance to stand for re-election
I'm Nell Amanda King cannot you fer
grass stubbies envelop it so for two
years are both a short and a long time
but it has allowed me to deal with
certain aspects of the policies that
were in place when I came to office
first of all I tackled the most pressing
issues within the first two weeks I
acted to bring down the high inflation
which was hurting the price of essential
foodstuffs and flush y'all as a fault
then I took on the economy I put in
place an economic plan that I called
emerging Senegal it was given strong
support by the international community
at a meeting in Paris foresees economic
growth in the order of 7% over the next
five to ten years dissolved in the
Battle of Prague I won't go into the
details of what has happened in
agriculture infrastructure health or
education I'm talking here about the
overall record we have strengthened the
rule of law and cynical fought to bring
criminal suspects to justice and
increase awareness of tax liability
you'll not say a week or two ago we
opened the National anti-corruption
office so a lot to improve the business
environment one key aspect of your
attempts to bring suspects to justice is
the trial against the former dictator of
Chad he sent ugly Senegal has set up a
special court the extraordinary African
chambers for the purpose a plane was
arrested in that car at the end of June
last year is the trial against him
proceeding on the supposed a country
singer boy well I was oozing I would not
call Ethan a player dictator as I'm not
permitted to use such a description
mr. Apple he was arrested at the request
of the African Chambers some African why
is it called African Chambers the
African Union gave Senegal the mandate
during the term of President Wadi to put
a buffet on trial in Senegal abre
Oh Senegal no no he changed our
constitution to allow the creation of
special chambers within the court of
appeal into calm African or sang the
cuckoo depended akka Hey Ozma once the
charge was made we were in a position to
appoint judges to the special African
Court which has been tasked with trying
this case I think the court will convene
soon prosecutors have already been
collecting testimony in cat as well the
proceedings are underway there will be a
ruling measure swept into further but I
hope there will be respect for human
dignity and the rights of the defense
until the question of guilt is
established it was when do you expect a
verdict for Mustafa no I can't say what
the ruling will be made I presume a
verdict will be reached after the
evidence has been presented but the
government has nothing to do with this
it's a purely legal man
Dossett effort by moving on to the
present chatty and president in Twista
beach wouldn't you say that he is using
the same strategy as his predecessors
ably bolstered his domestic position by
opposing Libyan dictator Muammar Gaddafi
for which he received US and French
support Dibby is sending troops into
Mali to distract from his restrictive
domestic policies do separately chicken
tell you I would not permit myself to
pass judgment on another African head of
state I'm not aware of any current
abuses in Chad if I were I would be in a
position to approach him that is not the
case when the African Union asked for an
intervention in Mali there was a great
need for it he has done a lot to restore
the honor of African armies he provided
one of the largest contingents of
alongside France and other countries at
a great cost for that we should thank
and congratulate him Massimo another war
félicité pasa la but not just you
Sebastian as for what is happening in
Chad we are a global village and nothing
can be hidden anymore we should not try
to depict his interventions in Mali or
Central African Republic as an attempt
to distract the international community
Tommy will clearly be another one of
your priorities is the conflict in Casa
Mons the area of southern Senegal that
has suffered a low level civil war for
more than 30 years what sort of progress
have you made in Cosimo's as for Casa
months was one of the first areas I
wanted to deal with it's impossible to
achieve economic stability in Senegal
when you have an unresolved conflict in
part of the country is room of younger
as I said about creating conditions for
a dialogue between the government and
representatives of the movement of
democratic forces in Casa malls or MFD
scene
whether they are underground or
politically active political in the
world
Paulo grab did you we are now fortunate
to have the sort of environment that has
never existed before
both sides are prepared to talk about
peace we haven't had any conflict for
more than two years now we haven't seen
any fighting any attacks it's a calm
situation that we can build on for
development or dispute oh man we are
holding separate talks with the two
factions of the MFT sea we are being
assisted by the community of Sant'Egidio
in rome and by two senior Senegalese
clergymen so when we're trying to create
conditions for a dialogue the currently
condition of the yellow may no no lose
some power no we're not just limited to
that we believe that peace should be
preceded with the development of
infrastructure that will help the local
population the population we have
recently launched a development plan for
Casa malls involving considerable
investment with the support of Senegal's
partners roads agriculture a situation
of women and reduce Casa malls isolation
we are doing this at the same time as
the talks and there are already signs
that the region is benefiting
economically I am confident that if all
sides show good will that there will be
lasting peace in Casa malls definite is
Germany playing in the development of
Senegal you met Chancellor Angela
Merkel's what projects are you planning
together
oh I saw a little of mine our
cooperation with Germany is not very
dynamic at the moment it goes back to
the years 2010 and 2011 when we were
having democratic problems and we
weren't a focus of interest we cut
ourselves off
nevertheless Germany is providing us
with 70 million euros to invest in the
renewable energy sector the Chancellor
and I agreed to renew our partnership
and expand beyond the sphere of
renewable energy in demas Samuel and I
expressed my wish to press on with the
rural electrification and
decentralization which is another of my
policies such as in Cosimo's - like this
uncle is a strong prosperous among we
would like to work with Germany in this
regard and also in vocational training
which is a real strength of the German
economy therefore we can benefit from
that model and German firms are coming
here rapport will be running the new
airport into car it's just the beginning
others will follow luck in Germany and
the EU do for West African stability
among Abdallah Germany is the number one
economy in the European Union and we
expect it to continue its efforts and
leadership regarding the European
development on the card of default open
the doors and also in its bilateral
relations with countries like Senegal I
also spoke to Chancellor Merkel about
Germany's role and its place in African
security so not secured an athlete in
the it is important to note that Germany
is already present in interventions with
soldiers but through logistics and
training as in the case in Mali there's
a small contingent into Karim I would
like this military cooperation in
security matters and in the fight
against terrorism to be stronger and
more visible swag or proof waterproof I
think Germany has a leading role in
Europe and the world
this leadership should also be apparent
in its dealings with Africa and its
European partners will see their part in
that all of that last question what
would you like the Senegalese and the
history books to say about you after you
leave office play life on the vote
Amanda so this would listen again I
would like to leave Senegal as a state
with a strong rule of law I would like
to achieve structural reforms of the
economy and to make direct foreign
investment a reality in Senegal I would
like there to be enough jobs and that
Senegal becomes an emerging the country
Senegal can have a strong rule of law
and a developing economy then I will
have fulfilled the mission that the
people entrusted in me and that I set as
my own objective fixico more objective
thank you very much mr. president for
this interview it was a great pleasure
to have you here
the pleasure's mine thank you